on pense que marca une autre maîtresse
et on veut savoir qui c'est quoi et vous
allez faire quoi exactement une fois que
vous aurez trouvé cette fille c'est une
opération à chaque jour suffit sa peine
aujourd'hui on va reconnaître le terrain
tranquille attention la cible bouge la
cible bougeard fait franchement je
reviens pas que ça t'intéresse pas elle
se lève je lui suis quoi je crois que
l'on peut faire sur mesure n'auront même
pas se faire sur mesure quand et
balancer comme ça tout va à la
perfection du tir il partait pour
regarde comment tu veux l'ancien se
tiendrait encore tre vainqueur était
régi anciens à un moment donné on dit je
joue au tennis d'accord mais j'y suis je
joue contre monsieur mcenroe
alors là je vais perdre c'est sûr que tu
dises kate quoi c'est moi mcenroe
mais qu'est ce que préfère
on vient
combattez les femmes ces normes
et du tlm